انتخابات تركيا الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه لفتت
الانظار الى الاستقطابات السياسيه الحاده
وبرامج الاحزاب المتنافسه لكن هناك قسم
كبير ومؤثر قد يلعب دورا العامل الحاسم في
تحديد النتائج وهم الجيل زد
الجيلزت فئه شباب من مواليد منتصف
التسعينات وحتى عام 2010 اي الذين تقل
اعمارهم عن 25 عاما يقدر عددهم بنحو 13
مليون فيقرب من نصفهم لم يصوت قط في اي
عمليه انتخابيه يصل عدد ما يحق لهم
التصويت بين هذه الفئه الى اكثر من سته
ملايين اي 12% من مجمل اصوات الناخبين وهي
نسبه حاسمه لاي من المترشحين
لم يعرف الجيل الزد في تركيا الزعيم سوى
ارضوان الذي يمسك بزمام الحكم في بلاده
منذ نحو عقدين ووزير بيال بطبعه الى
التجديد والتغيير
استطلاعات الراي تشير الى الحيااز
غالبيتهم للاحزاب المعارضه بدل التحالف
الحاكم بين حزبي العداله والتنميه بزعامه
اردوغان والحركه القوميه الذي يقوده دوله
باتشيلي لكن
ذهاب اصوات هذه الفئه لمرشح المعارضه
كليتشار اولو ليس مضمون الايض
ضبابيه المزاج الانتخابي لهذه الفئه
الشبابيه تعود لاسباب لخصها مركز
للابحاث التركي بالبحث عن نظام ديمقراطي
وخيبه امل ازاء الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والمعيشيه ابرزها البطاله ما يعني ان
الصناديق الاقتراب خلال الانتخابات
المقبله ستعكس توجهات الشباب في تركيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار البرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات